retrouvez dans l'émotion de la natif tu
peux déjà le temps le natif nouvelle
ligue de football américain entièrement
contrôlée par ses partisans est sur le
point de voir le jour
depuis que le sport professionnel existe
c'est des riches hommes d'affaires qui
ont pris toutes les décisions
mais dans la femme contrôle football
league se sont non c'est le fan femmes
femmes femmes
c'est donc bien le contrôlé par les
femmes
pas par les femmes pour que ça serait
quand même pu faire une ligue contrôlé
par les femmes fait même un peu
souhaitez vous promet de vous rapporter
toutes les pires décisions qui seront
prises par vous les femmes
la première est d'ailleurs d'avoir
sélectionné comme quart arrière d'une
des quatre équipes
johnny menzel un ex-joueur étoile
universitaire qui a toujours préféré
faire le parquet à avoir une carrière
professionnelle réussie cette algue est
bien partis quand tu prends les mêmes
décisions pour décor que les alouettes
de montréal jack nicholson en plus de
joueurs les fans pourront choisir les
entraîneurs les règlements ainsi que les
jeux en temps réel sur la plateforme
twitch qui diffuse les matchs pour vous
inscrire d'ailleurs sur le site web de
la fan quand tu joues au foot dans l'île
pour faire partie d'une des quatre
équipes en tant que partisan fondateur
je me suis inscrit on dit souvent que
les joueurs de la lnh en séries optent
pour le look vikings avec leurs barbes
vraiment bien fourni mais le défenseur
des sharks brent burns lui opus et
l'idée maximum en devenant ni terreau
allemands indiquaient ils incarnent deux
ans mais ce kane dans deux épisodes de
la série vikings sans avoir trop besoin
d'une mise en plis pour camper le rôle
du féroce guerrier quoique quand on
regarde la photo sur le site imdb ont
dit qu'ils avaient pas toujours la bonne
guerre de l'emploi pour camper le rôle
on ne sait pas s'il va gagner un autre
ennemi comme pour ses publicités au
panier des sharks c'est un emile moins
que sidney crosby qui a gagné un
deuxième en septembre
clairement pas possible tu m'entends tu
davos top 3 des résolutions
2021 qui ont déjà été prises
j'en avais cas mais dans le 4 2 4 g
toute autre personne top cas d'octroi sa
part le monde peut avoir avec la banque
non non rien n'est trop n'ont rien dans
notre top 3 ou 4 au modèle de hockey
junior cet arbitre a incité les joueurs
à rester positifs et négatifs
ils ont écouté
aucun joueur a échoué un test qu'aux
vide en attendant on n'est jamais trop
prudent avec sa santé buccale et
stéphane daigle et bi zogbo flow a été
pris en flagrant délit de se passer la
fraude en terre sur les lignes de côté
l'entraîneur jeff fisher date exacte et
un m a décidé de se remettre en forme
afin d'être capable d'éviter les 12 de
gatorade lui reste maintenant seulement
s'entraîner à la canadienne avec son
entraîneur personnel
laurent du var et à l'impact de montréal
s'est encore une fois fait ce coupé
l'annnonce de son nom cette fois par
l'équipementier adidas qui a dévoilé sur
son site web un nouveau t-shirt au nom
de cf
montréal club de foot montréal comme
quoi parfois ça serait mieux laisser les
fans schwazer de ce commando nouveau
t-shirt ce n'est pas rien non il plus
disponible
mais moi mon avis ce correct si tu
gagnes pas dépendre du vivier à son
prochain